[Music]
oh hey it's your girl miko i'm a food
blogger over at mikko on the dish you
can find me on instagram at miko in the
dish today i'm going to be showing you
the three ultimate peach recipes for the
summer the first is a grilled peach
panini the second is a sweet and spicy
peach sticky wing and the third is a
classic peach cobbler alright so let's
talk a little bit about peaches peaches
are best during the summer between the
time of may and september to pick the
perfect peach i like to do the press
test i'll go ahead and press my thumb
into the peach and if it gives a little
bit then i know it's the perfect peach
if it gives too much or if it doesn't
give it all then those aren't the good
ones so the first dish we're going to
make today is a grilled peach panitti
first things first i'm going to show you
how to take the pit from the middle of
our peach what i like to do is take my
knife into the peach until i feel the
pit in the middle and then i use that as
a guide to go around the entire peach
normally if you have a pretty ripe peach
you can break the two apart and you'll
have one side that is free of a pit and
one side that actually has the pitton so
this is where you're going to need to do
the work what i like to do from there is
take my knife sink it into the surface
of the peach going around the pit and
voila you have a pit-free peach now all
we have to do is slice the peach so i'll
just start guiding my knife thinly
slicing all the way through making sure
to cuff my fingers so that i'm not
cutting off my nails and these are
perfect slices for panini nice and thin
but still juicy and full of flavor all
right let's start making our panini i'm
starting off with some sourdough and i
normally will use either a homemade
pesto or sorbet pesto store-bought pesto
is totally fine for this i like a nice
juicy sandwich so i'm gonna be pretty
generous with my pesto the key to
layering your panini is making sure you
stack appropriately so what i'll do is
i'll get some brie cheese and i like to
add it making sure that everything is
kind of centered you don't want anything
leaning too far to one side because then
as you press down it'll move it'll shift
and so you want to make sure that that
doesn't happen that looks good to me i'm
going to add some thinly sliced peaches
i'm going to add a little bit of
balsamic vinegar that's going to give me
that extra acid that punch of flavor it
looks amazing so i am using room
temperature butter i am going to be very
generous there and then we're going to
get our panini press ready it's about
medium medium high i'm going to do a
little backup with some cooking spray
just to make sure
to make sure that there's no
extra sticking going on and then i'm
going to take my bread and i'm going to
flip it onto the panini press and
carefully set that down ooh i can hear
the sizzle while it's in the panini
press spread the remaining tablespoon of
butter on the top
oh all right it looks like our panini is
ready oh my goodness you can see the
cheese oozing out everything's looking
good but i'm gonna set this aside i'm
gonna work on a little side salad to go
with our peach panini so what i like to
do as a quick tip is i like to grill my
peaches on the panini press so they get
some of those really cute grill marks oh
look at these the grill marks are
amazing i am so excited i'm going to
dress my arugula with a little bit of
olive oil a little bit of balsamic
vinegar do a little toss toss toss and
then i'm going to add in my beautiful
peaches and there you have it the
perfect grilled peach panini with a
arugula and grilled peach salad oh my
goodness this is so amazing i absolutely
love it it is the perfect summer lunch
but if you're looking for something with
a little bit more heat you should try
the sweet and spicy peach sticky wings
these sticky wings are perfect for a
good game night dinner you really can do
it for almost anything but first things
first we need to start with the dry rub
we had a chipotle powder smoked paprika
baking powder onion powder garlic powder
kosher salt cayenne pepper italian
seasoning cumin powder and black pepper
so once you get them all into the bowl
make sure that they're all evenly
distributed so i have a bowl of chicken
wings the actual flats have been
separated from the drums i'll put oil
onto the actual wings and this is going
to give it a nice coating so that the
dry rub sticks to it really nicely and
then i'm going to add in my dry rub and
i normally like to do it in little
portions just to make sure that the dry
rub gets across all of up i said i like
to do in portions but it all went in and
that's okay because i'll use my hands in
order to evenly incorporate it across
all of the different wings and some of
it will get to the bottom so i'll just
use that to make sure it gets over all
of the wing the body of the entire wing
all right everything looks pretty well
incorporated i'm going to add my wings
onto the cookie sheet i spaced them out
so that the air can circulate around the
wing and so that they crisp up really
nicely
[Music]
while my wings are baking i'm going to
get started on my glaze i'm starting off
actually with a little secret canned
peaches and i love cam peaches because
you can use them year round so you can
enjoy this dish no matter what time of
the year it is so i'm going to add my
canned peaches into my skillet then i'm
going to add some brown sugar apple
cider vinegar
soy sauce i'm adding some sriracha for a
little bit of spice because i love spice
on my wings we've got some cinnamon
that's going to bring out that warmness
in the dish some black pepper and salt
our final ingredients are a dry bay leaf
and some water all right so now i'm
going to stir this all up once it
reaches a boil then i'll turn down the
temperature and let it reduce down for
another 15 minutes the first thing i'm
going to do to complete the glaze is i'm
going to remove that bay leaf i'm going
to carefully add my peaches to my
blender
we need to put it through a fine mesh
strainer so we have a really beautiful
and smooth glaze what we want to do is
we want to turn the heat back up we want
to bring our glaze to a boil so that it
thickens for about five minutes we're
gonna add some chilled butter to it just
wanna make sure that the butter fully
incorporates into the entire glaze i'm
gonna take about a third of the glaze
and just brush the entire
surface of each of the wings you really
want to make sure that you get the
entire wing on this round so you want to
turn them over get both sides fully
glazed now it's time to put it back in
the oven for five minutes i'm going to
add some glaze on the outside of each of
the wings and we're adding the glaze in
layers so once you take a bite out of
that wing you are hit in the face with
all this summer peachiness it's going to
be absolutely delicious we're going to
flip and get the other side you want to
make sure that these wings are fully
fully glazed
ooh this looks amazing so i'm adding the
wings to a bowl and then top them with
our glaze for a final toss so these are
going to be super triple layered glossy
yummy wings i'm going to add these to
our plate and then you should have a
little residual glaze that you can just
kind of pour over the top and let run
down the rest of the chicken these wings
look amazing already but i'm gonna go up
another notch and top with a little bit
of cilantro just to add a little bit of
color my goodness these look incredible
look at these wings they look juicy
smothered extra peachy with all that
peach glaze
the peach flavor and the crunch just
comes right through it's absolutely
incredible this is an amazing
sticky wing so i've already shown you
two amazing peach recipes but let me
tell you this last one is a classic a
good old peach cobbler it is the
quintessential southern summer dessert
so to get started we have to first peel
a beach what i like to do is take a
little paring knife here and i'll guide
the knife along the outer skin of the
peach making sure not to dig into the
skin too much and we're pretty good to
go and then we're going to go ahead and
remove the pit as you can see it's a
little bit stickier it's not giving up
that pit
so i like to try to see if i can get a
twist on it and it's not giving in so
what i'll do in this case is i'll
basically quarter it while it's on the
pit we've got a slice so this should
help us get closer to the pit and allow
us to start taking off more slices it
held on to the very end it's time to
make our filling i'm starting with some
brown sugar a little cinnamon
nutmeg those are going to add some
really nice warm spices to it vanilla
because there's really no desserts
without vanilla i like to add a little
citrus note so i'll add some lemon juice
salt which helps bring out some of that
sweetness and pepper that's my secret
ingredient now i'm going to add my peach
slices give it a little gentle stir so
that the heat evenly distributes around
all of the ingredients
this looks absolutely delicious it's a
little bit loose for me i like a thicker
peach filling so what i like to do is
take a little bit of cornstarch and add
a little bit of the syrup to make a
slurry and that will thicken up the
peach filling and i'll just pour this in
around and we're going to bring this to
a boil and it should thicken up in just
a few minutes you can tell when the
peach filling is ready because it's
gotten a little thicker there's a lot
more body to the juice and it's no
longer translucent it's actually opaque
now now you can totally start off with a
homemade pie crust i love homemade but
today i'm actually going to use a
store-bought pie crust because it makes
it go by so much quicker what i start
off with is a little bit of flour and
i'll flour my surface so i've got my
first pie crust rolled out i'm actually
going to add a second pie crust to this
bottom layer because i like my pie crust
to be just a little bit thicker if you
find like i just did that your dough
starts to break apart it's quite all
right don't sear we'll just use our
rolling pin in order to combine them and
bring them all back together into shape
once i'm ready
to get to transferring my pie crust what
i'll do is i'll add a little bit of
flour for transport and i'll just roll
my crust onto the rolling pin
so now i'll just take my pie crust and
roll it out right along the edges of the
pan so i'm going to lift these sides up
just so it makes sure that we can fold
these a little bit later and now our pie
crust is ready for our filling
what i like to use is a slotted spoon
that way it drains off any excess juices
and i can control the amount of juices
that are actually going into my pie
crust all right there goes my last scoop
of peaches i'm gonna make sure that my
peaches are spread out evenly across the
crust so i like to keep my syrup don't
dispose you can add this onto the ice
cream at the very end next step is i'll
dot butter across like so this is a
southern dish you can't get away with
not using butter here so now i'm going
to add my last pie crust topping now i'm
no crimping pie crust expert but what i
will do is i'll fold my pie crust
all around to make sure that the top and
bottom crusts are sealed what i do next
is i'll take some egg yolk and i'll do a
wash along the pie dough and that's
going to create a beautiful golden brown
crust i create a quick cinnamon sugar
stir those two together
and sprinkle that liberally across the
top i'll cut three large slots into the
top of the crust now my cobbler is ready
to bake it looks incredible i cannot
wait to dig in oh my goodness look at
that oh you can see that flaky crust and
those juicy peaches that is exactly
what i am looking for and no peach
cobbler is ever complete without a heavy
scoop of vanilla ice cream so remember
that syrup that i mentioned earlier
we're going to add that right over the
top oh i can't get my spoon fast enough
whoa that is incredible the crust is
flaky and buttery the peaches are
velvety and smooth and sweet they've got
that warm flavor from cinnamon and
nutmeg and that cold ice cream against
the warm filling is perfect peach
cobbler is my favorite dessert of all
time i love peach cobbler you absolutely
have to try this and those are my three
ultimate peach recipes for the summer i
enjoyed each and every one i hope you
did too we have the grilled peach panini
we have our sweet and spicy sticky wings
and finally we close things out with my
favorite peach cobbler which one was
your favorite let me know in the
comments below or let me know what your
favorite peach recipe is you can find me
on instagram at mikko and the dish until
next time
peace
oh yes
[Music]
you